barate en khâgne à expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir baratin de kalia merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on évoque avec vous cette quarantaine
imposée aux voyageurs au royaume-uni
c'était une mesure nécessaire selon
l'épidémiologiste que vous êtes
c'est une nécessité pour tous les pays
en tout cas s'il souhaite endiguer
l'épidémie et il faudra attendre
longtemps avant de voir les résultats
tout d'abord il faut réduire le nombre
de cas maintenir un niveau bas et
stopper l'introduction de nouveaux cas
dans le pénis et pourquoi
c'est à ce moment là que la quarantaine
sera utile en quoi précisément justement
expliquez nous le fonctionnement et en
quoi est ce nécessaire selon vous ça
veut dire que chaque pays
voilà gérer ce virus réussi peut-être
endiguer l'épidémie pour certains et 140
m ça pourrait repartir à l'échelle
notamment européennes voire mondiales
yes indeed sophos europe 1 une fille
européenne et le royaume uni doivent
être très clair sur ce point il faut
réduire et presque supprimer l es4 au
sein des pays
mais dans le même temps qu il faut
également éviter l'introduction de
nouveaux cas dans le pays depuis
l'étranger ou qu'il faut réduire le
nombre des cas au sein du pays et en
même temps en parallèle empêcher
l'arrivée de nouvelles mans les
infections donc il faut faire c'est deux
choses en même temps les mesures de
quarantaine prendront un certain temps
parce que nous avions déjà beaucoup de
cas dans notre propre pays et il faut
traiter déjà ce sujet aujourd'hui
ces mesures de quarantaine on en parle
entre le royaume uni et la france mais
ce que elles doivent est applicable avec
tous les pays du monde
selon vous quel serait l'intérêt est
appliqué sa quarantaine seuls quelques
ont construit les virus ne respectait
pas à les frontières les clôtures ou
deux personnes le virus existent dans le
monde entier
donc il faut renforcer les frontières
les mesures de quarantaine devrait
rester à ce niveau de la quarantaine il
s'agit de vous confier pendant 14 jours
afin de s'assurer que vous n'êtes plus
contaminés et que vous n'êtes plus con
terminant donc il ne s'agit pas de
laisser entrer les gens dans le pays
tout simplement en le confinant pendant
14 jours
il faut avoir un suivi s'assurer que au
bout de 14 jours
la personne était en bonne santé afin
qu'elles puissent se déplacer sans
contaminer personnes est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas faire d distinguo entre les
pays où il ya des cas par exemple brésil
aujourd'hui on sait que voilà ça explose
malheureusement en amérique latine et
des pays comme la nouvelle zélande qui
annonce aujourd'hui qu'elle a totalement
vaincu le virus avec juste 0 k voilà
dans tout le pays est ce qu'on doit pas
faire quand même des distanciation
absolue clé et oui non tout à fait le
problème c'est que nous savons que la
nouvelle zélande se porte très bien avec
zéro mais volkan
mais nous ne savons pas ce qu'il en est
pour d'autres pays je suis d'accord avec
vous si quelqu'un vient à zeeland
directement de vase et l'inde qui s'agit
d'un vol direct entre la
nouvelle-zélande et le royaume-uni et
qui ne rencontrer personne sur ce vol
alors il n'y aura aucun risque
d'infection mais s'il est ainsi
difficile complexe de vérifier cela que
des contrôles et des mesures de
quarantaine
sont tout de même nécessaire cependant
je suis également d'accord avec vous des
pays comme la nouvelle zélande
représente presque très bas et des pays
comme le brésil l'afrique ou l'inde
représente un très haut risque
vous comprenez enfin c'est peut-être
moins votre domaine vous êtes
épidémiologistes et est pas un analyste
des situations mais enfin vous comprenez
quand même le désarroi des compagnies
aériennes qui qui joue gros parce que ça
veut dire que si on impose une
quarantaine aux voyageurs ces derniers
ne vont plus vraiment vous allez voyager
c'est trop contraignant
je suis d'accord avec vous et mon
conseil pour l'année des mines fin c'est
de se rendre compte que c'est un une
situation très difficile toile de mater
qu'il faut essayer de réduire le nombre
de nouveaux cas partout sur la planète
et donc je propose d'annuler l'année
domine temps de ressentir tous ses
problèmes toute cette douleur tous ces
migraines et d'attendre 2021 où on
espèrera le virus aura disparu et je ne
pense pas que nous ayons beaucoup
d'autres options
oui reset 2020 c'est une idée merci en
tout cas à baratte bank kenya d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france